if it's worth doing it's worth doing  well I shortcuted so much stuff when I  was younger I just wanted to like get it  done rather than doing it well because  many times I was doing things that were  not worth doing I didn't have the time  to do things well because I was doing so  many things that were not worth doing  the first criteria is what problem are  we solving what am I hoping to  accomplish is this worth doing at all if  it is worth doing then I have to  understand that to do it to do it well  it's going to take this much time now  given that is it still worth doing and  if it passes that test then it gives us  this lens through which to see the  activities we do so that we can  prioritize the things that will make us  the most money or get us closer to the  goals we have